what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back to finishing up moon night
which i realized we didn't finish up
volume one i need to go through and
figure out the stories that we haven't
finished and finish those up because i
feel like they've just been lingering
too long right the channel feels like
it's been a little chaotic recently and
so what this does here kind of finishing
out this this first volume here uh this
kind of picks up after the events of his
fight with bader now for those of you
guys who don't recall that uh that was
basically the second fist of konshu that
moon knight was not the only one he was
not the only one to ever receive the
power of khanshu and to basically become
a moon knight that uh that vader was as
well he just kind of operated behind the
scenes now the reality is that's a
retcon he's a newly created character
it's just jed mckay's way of throwing
him into the story and introducing him
as a new guy with a backstory of his own
but one of the things that happens here
is you have a conversation that
initially takes place between moon
knight and his therapist and one of the
things she asks here is why do you wear
a mask right like what's the the point
of wearing a mask and initially he
starts talking about how when he wears
this mask that he's that basically that
he's not mark specter right and he's he
says he's not really talking about his
disassociative identity disorder right
it's multiple personality disorder then
instead mark specter in and of himself
doesn't really matter he doesn't really
have any actual purpose or really even
any value in the world that in a lot of
ways he is an identity that doesn't
serve a useful purpose and that as the
fist of konchu moon knight is a symbol a
dead man brought back in the pursuit of
justice he says my masked face is the
face of konshu it's part of my vestments
the same as my costumes right the same
way that captain america has a shield or
spider-man has his outfit or iron man
has his armor it's a part of who he is
and that's the reason why he wears the
mask now there is actually a larger
motivation to this and is one of the
cooler elements of his character but in
the midst of all this what we end up
doing is switching over to stuart clark
now stewart clark has been around in
marvel comics for a long time and
originally he was a villain of the first
champions team but the thing about this
is that stuart clark didn't always look
this way so this guy has been a kind of
tour de force when it comes to marvel
comics he's kind of been everywhere and
been involved in a lot of different
things after his original appearances in
the old champions comics there came a
point when he was involved in
banetronics which is actually ran by
madame menace it's technically part of a
company called sunset bane but basically
and we didn't really even find out about
this until iron man vol 3 issue number
19. uh that basically she had stolen
information or stolen knowledge of stark
tech by seducing tony stark and then
used that to essentially build her own
company using stark technology and then
weaponizing it and basically becoming
like an underground arms dealer in the
aftermath of the original civil war
event he actually became an information
and arms broker for uh for frank castle
for the punisher um i mean he has he's
fought both against and for billy russo
the original jigsaw this guy's been
everywhere uh it wasn't really until the
events shortly after at least during and
shortly after secret invasion that his
face ended up getting all scarred the
way that it was ultimately he was
believed to have been killed and we
never really found out exactly how it
was that he came back we simply just
know that he did but in this moment
right now he's basically having a
conversation with a mystery man that he
knows nothing about who essentially says
i can help you destroy moon knight but i
can help you bring this guy down and
essentially gives stuart clark the
ability to access uh basically steve
grant's financial accounts now remember
steve grant is one of the identities of
mark specter right one of the the
personalities of moon knight remember
he's very similar to batman in that way
so in a lot of ways uh steve grant is
like the bruce wayne persona of moon
knight and so what ends up happening
here is there's a couple things that go
on one of the first things is that mark
specter is visited by tigra and this is
really just because of the fact that
they're old friends right they were
avengers at one point they're just kind
of talking and hanging out and spending
time together she'll be kind of become a
kind of unofficial member of the team
but the other thing that happens here is
that mark gets a call from stuart clark
who basically says i have total command
over all the funding of steve grant and
i know that's how you fund your midnight
mission and he's like just right here
watch bam and he's like a million bucks
is gone just like that right just gone
disappeared it doesn't exist and he's
like i'm gonna keep on doing that unless
you work for me unless you do what i
tell you to and so ultimately he ends up
sicking him on some guys and it actually
turns out to be the forces of billy
russo of jigsaw and so of course moon
knight gets in there starts tearing all
these guys up gets into a fight with
jigsaw and then basically takes jigsaw
out we don't really see it happen it
just kind of happens off panel it's one
of those things where it's like well you
know now let's fight and then you just
kind of skip to the next scene so it's
kind of a foregone conclusion in terms
of how this happens but more so than
that what actually ends up going on here
is that when stuart clark tries to call
moon knight back in order to send him on
another mission we end up finding out
moon knight basically trace his location
it's kind of what you expected and then
he just beats the hell out of this guy
right he just absolutely puddles this
guy now one of the things that goes on
though is that before stuart clark is
ultimately defeated he actually starts
zapping all the money of of steve grant
and reduces moon knight down to being a
guy who's completely and totally broke
the crazy thing about this is moonai
says i don't care it was never about the
money right like my mission is to help
people who are in need right travelers
in the night that's my that's my job i
don't need money to do that right i
don't i don't need like all these
resources i mean money makes it easier
and you're really inconveniencing me
right now
right he's like but i only serve my
people those who petition for my help
and this is kind of a change of pace
from the nature of moon knight as we've
seen him in years past it's one of the
reasons why jed mckay's moon knight run
is very reminiscent of like the old
school moon night run from like the 70s
right like way back in the day moon
night we haven't really seen him
depicted in this way in quite some time
in a lot of ways in recent years moon
knight's just kind of been a guy who's
there who does some things and like was
on the avengers once and that was it
there really wasn't a whole lot going on
with his character there wasn't a whole
lot of development he had some cool
stories but outside of what is it jeff
lemire's run there really had not been a
significant moment for moon knight
certainly not on the same level as the
kind of development that we're seeing
here which is one of the reasons why i'm
just so into the story but again one of
the other things that kind of goes on is
that where the answer he gave his
therapist is that the reason why he has
the mask on is because mark specter
doesn't matter all that kind of cool
stuff that what he actually says here is
that he has a family he's got like a
wife and daughter right that he found
out that he has a kid and that they
essentially ended up taking off like to
the other side of the world that they
they never wanted him to come after them
because he was just so dangerous right
the the life he lives is dangerous his
disassociative identity disorder his
multiple personalities make him
dangerous right it's the kind of thing
where in a lot of ways mark spector has
lost more than he gained and that's why
he told tigra the real reason that he
wears this mask is because he doesn't
like to have to look himself in the face
whenever he's looking in a mirror that
he can lie about who he is and this is
stupendously important because what this
really does is it seems like is jed
mckay hitting on why it is that mark
specter even has multiple personalities
in the first place that usually as i
understand it when it comes to
developing multiple personalities it's
usually a highly traumatic event that
leads to that taking place that a
personality manifests as a coping
mechanism for a traumatic experience and
that while moon knight has had all kinds
of traumatic experiences over the course
of his life this just feeds into it but
the motivation being he doesn't like who
he sees when he looks in the mirror
while the the front-facing idea of that
is that's why he puts on the mask i
would go as far as to say that's why the
personalities of steve grant and like
jake lockley and mark spector why they
still continue on because at the end of
the day he's running from his own
history he's running from his own past
and the kinds of things that he's been
involved in here and so what we end up
doing is basically switching over to a
guy that meets with him and says i know
who it was or who it is that's been
attacking you from behind the scenes i
know the person who was basically the
one that sent uh that sent like bader
after you or at least told him of your
location i know the one who sent stuart
clark after you like i know what's going
on here now this kid that appears to him
is simply a kid named terry now there's
a lot more to him than initially than
there initially appears to be and in
fact there's more history to him than i
think most people know but the thing
about this is that he essentially says
like the person who's basically been
coming after you the person behind all
this is soldier now one thing to know
and when he leads the leads mark specter
to like the base of soldier there's like
a picture of soldier with uh hydra
tattoos things like that obviously
alluding to the fact that soldier has a
sketchy history and this is not like a
faked photo this is an actual photo and
so all the evidence really points to a
soldier as being the one that's behind
this now remember soldier is one of the
people that mark spectre had helped kind
of one of his inside guys that he's
largely been working with and so in
essence it's almost like he was betrayed
from the inside now as he's hunting for
soldier and trying to figure out what's
going on there is a point where he
switches over to this conversation with
his therapist and one of the things that
goes on and it's kind of a monologue
that sort of takes place here which is a
little lengthy so bear with me but it's
exceedingly profound and probably one of
the best monologues that mark specter
has that as he's talking to his
therapist that what he says here is
there's being raised jewish and then
there's being raised by a rabbi right
because mark specter is jewish and he
says my father was the kindest gentlest
man i've ever known but there was never
anything kind or gentle in me he was a
man of peace he hated violence and i
thought that made him weak a weak man
serving an indifferent god because those
were our stories weren't they we lost
our homes our land we were enslaved and
then escaped out into the desert and
from then up until now we took our licks
from practically everyone my father
taught me it was our perseverance that
was our greatest quality as a people how
we never gave up our faith our laws our
covenant with god how we would laugh to
keep from crying no matter what happened
to us so when i died in selma can you
blame me for accepting konchu's offer i
put aside a god who had let terrible
things happen to his people a god who i
had never seen never heard in favor of a
god who spoke right to me and promised
join me be my son and together we will
get things done and the response this
therapist offers is no one can blame you
for wanting to live but he says that's
just it isn't it all my life i thought
that my father was weak because he was
kind and gentle and would never raise a
hand in violence but he would have died
before he broke faith with god before
recognizing another god that the bible
says you shall never have other gods
before me for i the lord your god am a
jealous god when it came down to it i
was the weak one i sold out everything i
had been raised to believe to save my
own neck to further indulge my addiction
to violence my father's god took us out
of egypt my new god kept us there and
when he's asked the question do you
regret that choice his response is of
course i regret serving kanchu i got my
life back and what good did it do me i
buried my father i killed my brother my
friends frenchie crawley gina and her
boys the lucky ones just hate me for
what being a part of my life did to them
the others are all dead and when i was
asked by my god to take down the
avengers and put boots on the world's
neck i did it and i did it well because
that's what i've always done as a marine
as a mercenary as moon knight i did what
i was told was the right thing to do no
matter what my eyes my ears my soul told
me but did it help a single person no
and now my kid and her mother are an
ocean away because they're scared of me
you couldn't understand before why i
take being the fist of conscience so
seriously when it's cost me so much and
he said it cost me everything he says
it's because i don't have anything left
if i'm not the fist of konshu whatever i
choose to understand that as when i'm
just mark specter the man who makes the
wrong choice every time the man who
threw away his religion his heritage
killed what family he didn't bury the
man who brought harm and trauma to
everyone who ever cared about him the
man who can't breathe from the guilt
closing over his head thick as seawater
and twice as bitter no wonder i
developed disassociative identity
disorder because i'd rather be anyone
else other than that guy how's that for
honesty this is this is probably one of
the single greatest monologues in the
history of moon knight and it explains
his character so well that the reality
here is mark spector is just a guy who
runs he's a guy who feels like he
betrayed himself he betrayed himself and
everything he stood for everything that
was important to him he threw it all
away just in the name of basically
surviving right in the name of like
wanting to live to continue his
addiction to violence his idea his life
as a mercenary killing people destroying
things right being the the total
antithesis of everything his father
believed and everything he was raised to
believe and so in the midst of this
great big huge monologue of course
there's a point where he realizes
there's a perimeter breach and then
ultimately ends up traveling to that
location to find that soldier is
basically locked up and of course he
ends up or at least has the idea of
freeing soldier but there's a
walkie-talkie there and he's basically
told by a disembodied voice that mark
spector has two options that in the end
soldier was framed soldier did have a
history with hydra but soldier is not
the one who's basically turning against
mark spector he's not the one that's
ratting him out right he's not the one
that's working against him behind the
scenes that it's somebody else who's
doing it the person on the other side of
this microphone and that's when he says
like mark spector i have watched you i
have watched you work i have watched you
function i've watched you do everything
that you do you are a selfish and a
terrible man so here is the option i
will give you either you can leave
soldier there and save yourself or you
can stay there try to free soldier and
you can die right you can try to cut the
chains you can try to remove them but
they're old chains the rusted chains
it's going to be ridiculously difficult
to do there's epoxy in the keyhole right
it's not going to be a simple thing of
picking a lock and getting them out
you're going to have to make the choice
and this bomb's already ticking so the
question is if you pop that uh that
acetylene torch that's built into your
glove using the last little tidbit of
money that you have if you decide to use
this and you decide to cut that chain
the question you have to ask yourself is
this what's gonna happen first are you
gonna be able to freeze soldier and
leave or is the bomb gonna go off and
ultimately the bomb explodes now of
course mark spector is able to get
soldier out of there and that's when
he's met by the arrival of terry and
that's when terry says like i
underestimated you mark spector right
this is going to be ridiculously fun you
and i are gonna have an absolute blast
and that's when he says you can call me
the zodiac now here's the thing this is
not a new creation by jed mckay the
zodiac's actually been around since dark
rain now whether or not jed mckay is
going to change the nature of the zodiac
we're not entirely sure but the way it
originally functioned is that zodiac was
basically a fan of anarchy which
according to the classic definition
essentially calls for the removal of all
power structures and depending on what
kind of other political philosophies you
apply it to communism things like that
even the removal of money but the belief
that people can function without any
sort of power structures at all uh
traditionally you could call it like a
return to a state of nature where people
just kind of existed out there in the
world but there was no real ordered
government in the traditional sense now
i'm sure somebody somewhere might say
well no that's not really what it means
okay sure whatever but the thing about
this is that that zodiac largely has
always worked to remove power structures
as they exist initially during dark rain
it was the aftermath of secret invasion
and the fact that norman osborne and his
guys had been put in charge of shield it
was always kind of operating behind the
scenes launching these small pot shot
attacks but the thing about this is that
this appearance of of zodiac is pretty
short-lived right i mean like mark asked
the question like are you gonna kill me
terry like go ahead you know i'll come
back just like i always do he says and
then i'm going to put you through a wood
chipper which is probably something moon
knight would do but in the end the
response of zodiac is why would i do
that right it's such a waste one of the
funny things about this and i'm sure you
guys can draw the parallel like that it
looks like jed mckay is basically
turning uh zodiac into like moon
knight's version of the joker right
where he's like i want to help you right
like i want to break you i don't want to
kill you i want to break you i want to
help you i want to make you better right
i want him i want to improve on you it's
a kind of of just psychopathic mentality
but it's pretty nuts now in the midst of
this great big huge fight of course
because of the fact that that zodiac
really goes to make the move with the
intention of taking out mark spectre or
at least damaging him in such a way that
it would basically break him mentally if
zodiac were to kill soldier that you end
up having rhys right the vampire
assistant essentially of moon knight who
goes running off to an ally and that
when that happened she's like mark
spector needs you like he absolutely
needs you you have to come and help him
and so in this moment when zodiac is
going to kill soldier that this help
basically arrives on the scene and no i
was as disappointed as you guys were
it's not blade
a part of me was so hoping it was going
to be blade and i feel like it was just
a massively wasted opportunity by jed
mckay it really would have been cool if
it was blade and we just had him up here
as a kind of thing here the real
question you have to ask is would blade
have just killed reese on the spot right
because she was a vampire and blade
takes no prisoners he don't ask
questions but ultimately it is a being
badir who basically saves uh mark
spector despite the fact that the two of
them are essentially enemies and because
bader has a history as a doctor he
actually ends up treating mark spector
and then ultimately ends up you know as
mark spector is kind of you know
recovering or at least you know kind of
passing out a little bit he's conscious
enough to be able to hear so he's kind
of in that space between like asleep and
awake you guys know what i mean you kind
of wake up at like 2 30 in the morning
you're a little asleep and a little
awake at the same time but uh but
essentially vader basically tells his
story to mark spector right in saying
that in his younger years he was a very
very serious person right he was born in
in luxor egypt that his parents were
both doctors and that he took after them
becoming a doctor himself and he says i
was as serious a child as i am now a man
i excelled in academics took to my
studies with a desire to learn i was a
model student in all subjects at the top
of my class even as a child but when i
compared myself to my peers to my family
to everyone i met i found myself wanting
it seemed everyone else had something
that i did not and he says i never felt
the presence of god not like any of the
others did and he says i study the quran
and all these other religious texts as
much as any of the other subjects did my
recitations were perfect my prayers and
practice were flawless and he says but
it was merely wrote to me i could not
make the spiritual connection that
everyone i knew seemed to and this
worried me what was missing in me i was
a very rational child and it seemed to
me that if i followed the correct
practice then i should get the correct
result and he says but that was not the
case and it hurt me incredibly deeply he
says outwardly i followed the correct
practices i attended prayer i studied i
did everything that was expected of me
but inwardly i grew to be a strict
rationalist i believed in nothing that i
could not see or touch and he says i
grew to be an adult in such a way i
followed my parents into medicine i was
a respectable man i had very few friends
but i am not friendly by nature so it
mattered little to me he says i kept my
lack hidden so that i could fit in it
was a good enough life all things
considered better than many have until
it was taken from me and he says it was
that night i was walking by myself as i
often did there's always danger in
walking alone at night there were
stories of strange attackers right
obviously speaking of vampires things
along those lines that ultimately he was
attacked by one but then he was brought
before the statue of konshu and when
that happened konchu appeared to him and
offered him the ability to have his life
saved offered him the ability to serve
as the other hand of khanshu opposite of
mark spector and that he would continue
living on that much like mark spector
himself where mark didn't really feel
the presence of god because he saw the
terrible things happening in the world
and couldn't really rationalize the idea
that if god truly loved the the children
of this world why would he let such
horrible things happen to him right that
kind of disconnect that sort of
hypocrisy that in his mind didn't seem
to make any sense bader did the exact
same thing the difference here is that
he was highly rational if it cannot be
acknowledged by his five senses as far
as he was concerned it simply didn't
exist and god fell into that purview
that god was not something he could see
or touch or taste or hear or anything
like that that you had to rely strictly
on faith in order to truly believe that
god was there but that konchu physically
appeared to him konchu spoke to him he
could smell khanshu i don't know if he
could taste kanchu it'd be weird if he
did but you guys understand that khanshu
confirmed his five senses and that in
that moment he basically felt a
connection that he hadn't felt before he
was drawn to this idea and so as mark's
spectre is basically wrapped up and as
he is entombed the response of a deer is
that once the the day passes and once
you're able to heal and you come back
out in the night you'll actually come
out stronger than you were before and so
in response to all this because the bomb
had basically exploded in the midnight
mission and because of the fact that
midnight mission was completely and
totally torched that in the end with
steve grant's money being gone the
questions asked why like reese and tegra
like what are we gonna do but as they're
heading back to the mission the various
people across the neighborhood are all
greeting them and in the end as far as
mark spector's concerned that's the
thing that matters most that while they
have lost their money and while the
midnight mission is in shambles the
thing that's the most important is
people thank them for their service that
people see mark spector as a protector a
person that keeps him safe or keeps all
of them safe and so in the end he
basically sets up a chair in the
midnight mission the whole thing is
totally torched but it's one of the
coolest looking moon night scenes ever
and he says i'm moon knight and i'm not
going anywhere so in essence the stage
is set and zodiac is now the main
villain of mark spectre which in reality
is the perfect choice but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace